pour la toute première fois les centres
communaux d'action sociale viennent se
ravitailler auprès de la banque
alimentaire depuis le confinement 22 des
33 associations qui oeuvrent auprès des
familles ne sont plus en mesure
d'assurer leurs missions
devant la misère des plus faibles les
crs commence donc à prendre le relais ce
matin une équipe du françois vient
prendre livraison 30 foyers ont été
identifiés ont fait des pentes à porte
on remarque qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes un peu isolée par des
personnes âgées
c'est au il ya d'autres personnes
monoparentales aussi et qui sont
personnes isolées sans transports
publics et privés des petits jobs
l'habituel les entrées d'argent
certaines sont identifiés par les
services sociaux mais combien restent
seuls il ya un grand musée a qu'un train
de s'installer dans le département
le fait que certaines associations ne
sont plus sous le tient forcément ça
pose des difficultés au niveau des ccls
de retrouver ces familles dont il ya
toute une procédure d' enquête presque
pour retrouver des familles en
difficulté qui forcément
parfois ne savent pas comment faire pour
pour s'alimenter
comment faire pour avoir de l'aide déjà
20 cseries de l'île font appel à la
banque alimentaire
ici la ville de ducos qui a identifié
une quarantaine de familles les besoins
sont tels que le partage et la
distribution comment souvent le jour
même dans l'île une douzaine
d'associations et toujours sur le
terrain comme souvent les plus
importantes comme la croix rouge ou le
fourneau mais ces deux jeunes feuilles à
l'aise continuent leur tournée
aujourd'hui huit familles les attendent
ce sont des familles qui avaient déjà
des problématiques sociales qui se sont
accrues par rapport à la situation
actuelle et sa leçon que aujourd'hui les
institutions ne fonctionnent pas
correctement donc les difficultés
informatiques deviennent plus
importantes les familles enfin oui c'est
un talent oui malheureusement à l'heure
où la banque alimentaire préparent
habituellement sa grande collecte la
première de l'année les perspectives
sont floues et c'est un entrepôt à
moitié vide qui contemple aujourd'hui
salariés et bénévoles depuis le début du
confinement
nous avons eu des ruptures de stock sur
des
et denrées de base le rize les pattes et
nous avons dû acheter
il y a certes de l'aide d'une façon
générale des entreprises
agroalimentaires et des grandes foires
des grandes surfaces mais très peu la
banque alimentaire a donc fait appel à
la fédération pour ses besoins
supplémentaires mais aussi à la ctm et
aux services de l'état pour des
subventions exceptionnelles
entre temps les fidèles qui s'activent
dans l'entrepôt continue à redoubler de
vigilance
avec lavage des mains toutes les heures
les infections des camions des
containers des glacières et des bacs à
chaque fois qu'une autre personne les a
touchés l'association ne peut décidément
se permettre demain de baisser le rideau